different our standards are different
for what we will sleep with here
compared to what we will be in a
relationship with like there's a lot of
girls that have had sex with guys that
are well out of their league because my
man just wanted to pass a knot with a
woman it's not like that you know i mean
a lot of women have to respect something
about you or rate something about you to
sleep with you my man could just be like
you know what she had a fat back bro and
leading on to the yeah that's where some
women get [ __ ] up because they start
sleeping with their say a five and they
start sleeping with a ten and if that's
one level
but if he doesn't actually want to be in
a relationship with you my love that's
not your level
but the whole the whole point is like as
a girl like we can just go down in looks
right if like so if a girl's a six say
she can go down and do get get a rich
three that's 25 years older be bailed
out of any bad decision she's ever made
it's not it's not that hard but i think
there are men that can no no but i'm
saying i'm saying what percent of men do
you really think can do that
i i don't know what the percentage if
you don't get all men that could do that
but we would agree would you agree it's
a very small percentage less than five
percent no it's not that you think it's
higher so why would you say it's higher
than that for women that are making good
money so so then their ratio of being
able to get a woman who is making good
money and they can live off her
goes up every year the more women that
i'm making so why would you say it's
higher than that when dating app data so
these are two separate studies right
they surveyed women and asked them what
men they found attractive and they said
less than nine less than 20 percent of
men they found attractive and on dating
apps when women swiped right they found
less than 20 of men attractive because
okay yeah go ahead
okay so when you're swiping or the
evidence is placed in front of you
you're going to be way more in your this
is what i'm after now when you're face
to face with somebody and you're hearing
their baritones and you're feeling their
pheromones and they're in front of your
face that will probably drop a little
bit more okay depending on if you're
ovulating if you're horny if they're
ready to go things change so data when
you're swiping on faces is very one way
i i agree with you so i i do think like
there are things that men can do right
they can be funny they can you know
they're like
they improve their odds but i would
still say it's a minority even if let's
say we double it let's give men 40
that's still that's still what percent
could actively live off of a girl
a small percentage even if we said 40
percent of men could get a check right
what percent what percent are good
looking and have enough game to live off
of a chance i agree or even live off
long term yeah some women might take it
for a year or two until they're like you
know what not whilst a man will a man
will take a man will happily marry a
woman who works at mcdonald's and you
can stay working on the rest of your
life and he's not going to trouble him
one little bit yeah but it couldn't work
you don't know
anybody
any woman that's the point i'm not
talking about
that are funding their whole households
and there is a mandate yeah but also
so you know what data also doesn't match
up with what you're saying what percent
of women make that much money the
average women and the us i know it's
similar here makes 35 000 a year that's
not enough to take care of a dude it's
not 35k that's the average that means
half of women make less than that so
it's a small percentage of women that
can even take care of a guy and then
also it depends on the woman's
circumstances as well it depends on her
circumstances because boy if you're a
single mom and you've got two youths
yeah and you've got a guy here that's a
bum yeah but he's giving you the wood
yeah but you might settle for that and
let man stay in the house because your
options ain't really there
but if you're young but if you're young
and you're good looking and you're
making money you're not tolerating that
so what i'm saying is yeah that guy even
yeah
my man's just she's just taking whatever
she can get because her options are just
not for that time for the time being and
then if another guy comes along that's
got more money than him she's gone
brother like that's because that's how
that's how they're wired they're always
looking for the next best thing and
that's okay
do you know what i'm saying that comes
to the fallacy of choice because you get
so much choice you think oh it's fine
i'll get someone better and then you
keep saying i'll get someone better
until you get to that point where you
know she's a single mom with two kids
and no money so she has to settle for
that guy
i often say a woman's dating career
follows the life of say like a
footballer like when you're 16 17 you
get a couple young g's like ronaldo
they're shelling it getting getting
better and better and better then they
hit their late 20s 30s and then suddenly
you don't get offered a new contract at
a top top club and then you start
scrambling it's almost like that for
women on a date at marketing and you're
in turkey
and then you start trying to revive by
doing bbl's really you're at the end of
your career and you should have just
made the best of the clubs that you're
at when you had the chance um